but I mean to a certain extent I only
partially understand this as well I
don't know where he came up with the
ideas doing this it's really came out of
left field this it was very strange and
people had enormous difficulty accepting
his ideas when they first came out but
in the end it was such a useful tool
that everybody adopted it
fireman diagrams are a wonderful way of
describing an interaction and it was
introduced the the notation was
introduced by Richard Fineman and they
have a very particular form they're
trying to describe events where you have
two particles imagine these two things
which I've stolen from George moving
together and bashing apart that's the
basic scattering process so firing came
up with this idea as as did another
physicist called stucco Berg who had a
similar idea but the name is stuck with
phiman for for this pictorial
representation and the idea I think is
fairly easy and the implications are
phenomenal of what you can do with them
but the idea is fairly easy now
if I were to think of time moving this
way then these two particles when
they're moving together like that if
time is moving that way I plotted a
graph where they come together with time
as time progresses that way and they
back apart so you know what your
incoming particles are this is called
your in state there could be electrons
there could be an electron and a
positron it could be anything coming in
because you can detect that you can also
detect the final particles out here they
may again be an electron and a positron
they may be photons now I'd like you to
imagine this is happening for a very
small particle a tiny particle okay well
electron for example we'll talk about
electrons scattering off an electron
electron scattering off its nemesis the
anti-electron the particle which were
wants to destroy it so this is going to
kill that one but what goes on in
between okay
that's the interaction that's when
fireman was doing his work he was
looking at the interactions between
electrons positrons and and light
photons is called QED quantum
electrodynamics they're coming together
and in between something strange happens
a particle of light a photon is emitted
from here in the quantum mechanical
version of this and is absorbed by that
one and they move apart so fireman
thought of that as a diagram where these
two particles these two electrons move
forward in time so they're moving this
way but time is running that way so
that's these two paths and at this stage
this particle gives out a particle of
light which he represented by a little
wiggly line like that and then this
particle is scattered and moves outwards
because it recoils as these two come
apart and another electron is scattered
off there and that's his version of the
idea that there's a Coulomb repulsion
between these two charged particles they
come together there are actually
collapse they get a collide they get
very close together and then they move
apart he you'd know what was coming in
you'd know what was going out and you
had to have a way of representing what
was going on in between and he came up
with this pictorial way because it turns
out it's not a simple one-to-one map
it's not that if you have two particles
coming in here there's only one way that
you'll get these two particles going out
there are many ways that when these two
come in these two can go out if it would
the antiparticle he would draw the
diagram somewhat differently he would
and what I'm doing is building little
building blocks of what's going on
quantum mechanically as I am making a
Lego model this is the particle this is
the antiparticle and it comes together
the electron and the anti electron and
it smashes together and creates nothing
but energy they come in equal opposite
momentum there's no momentum there's a
huge amount of energy which is releases
a photon in the quantum mechanical
process and then this entity is taken
away and this might produce something
else
there's no reason why it has to be
electron it might produce a muon an anti
melon and what the Fineman diagram does
it it allows you to work out all the
possible combinations of the particles
which will lead to a given end state
from each diagram you can work out the
probability of that event occurring I
was thinking of a trend think of an
analogy when students leave their houses
to come to university you know at the
beginning is it's their leaving their
houses and you're at the end pointers
they've arrived in the university but
they can go all different routes and and
some routes are more probable you know
the most direct routes the most probable
and then routes round back streets are
less probable but you could map it you
could actually map if you want you start
here and you end here and you can draw
these different routes and then you can
give a weighting or a probability for
each of them and this is what fine and
diagram does but it does it for the
particles oh here's another one which is
quite fun this is the particle whizzing
along in time forwards in time and it
says I don't feel very nice I'm a bit
naked I like to dress myself so it
actually says I'll have one of those
going on I'll omit this photon and then
I'll absorb it again oh I can have
another one on top of that I can have a
one that goes around from there to there
and so it has a whole series rather like
Pig pinning in Charlie Brown you
remember the character that walked along
and had a cloud of dust around him had
this horrible cloud carrying all the way
through the cartoon strip well this is
the electron travels along and carries
along with it a virtual cloud of these
particles photons fluctuating around it
all the time and this is called a self
energy correction and it affects the
mass of the particles which is no longer
the same as the mass you started with
but corrects it and firemen turn these
diagrams which seem so Elementary into a
mathematical language which created a
field theory which is incredibly
accurate articles come in the interact
Bank
bang bang bang bang and outgo other
particles you know what's coming in you
know what's going out and the fireman
diagram is a procedure that allows you
to work out which is the most likely
route to get to those that outcome and
it plays a huge role in particle physics
he made the complex language of quantum
field theory as invented by Schwinger
into a language which with a set of
rules anybody could do he made the whole
landscape clear for example the all the
work that's going on at CERN at the
Large Hadron Collider they're looking
for this infamous Higgs particle okay
and they're looking for dark matter
particles and they're looking for
evidence of supersymmetry one of the
guiding principles they use to determine
how to go to look for these particles of
these Fineman diagrams so this language
which professional physicists use
theoreticians use then finds
applications not only in elementary
particle physics and solid-state physics
as well so you can talk about electrons
in a superconductor exchanging photons
between them now not photons phonons the
electrons couple through phonons and
that's the basis of superconductivity so
this language permeates all of
theoretical physics there can be really
complex and so the when you're a
graduate student and you first do a
particle physics course and you indeed
do do these simple basic Feynman
diagrams in fact they do then the
undergraduate levels now at the most
basic diagrams they're called the tree
level diagrams they're the first-order
diagrams they often will be the ones
that dominate but they don't always then
there are but there are other as I said
you know you don't always go the direct
route there are perhaps lots of other
ways of reaching that particular Finals
final stage and and there can be
extremely complicated but when you're
doing these calculations to work out
things like masses of particles
strengths of couplings you actually have
to include all the possible combinations
and and so you have to be able to go
through these narrow backstreet
it's the equivalent of them to get to
the final outcome